we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
hey David I really like your show um I'm
a caretaker for a man with early-stage
Alzheimer's and dementia and last year
when I saw Trump I thought oh my god she
acts so much like the man I am taking
care of especially the way he can't read
papers very long or concentrate very
long and I was wondering or how is he
going to be president if he doesn't have
a caretaker by him well as soon as he
put his daughter in with him
I was thinking aha there's his caretaker
so that's my opinion
Thanks yeah so in the last 24 to 48
hours our story from last month about
Trump showing early signs of dementia or
Alzheimer's has gone viral it might have
a million views by the end of the week a
dozen or so news outlets have picked up
the story and many people like this
caller have called in saying I have a
family member that experienced dementia
Alzheimer's I am a caretaker for someone
with dementia Alzheimer's and what you
identified in Donald Trump is very
similar to what I observe in my family
member or the person that I am taking
care of people that presumably don't
know each other getting in touch and
saying that it is very interesting that
that's going on certainly interesting
but also not something we can really
prove at this point of course Harold
Bornstein which is Trump's doctor isn't
going to come out and say this well you
know we found out Ronald Reagan had
Alzheimer's perhaps during his
presidency and that took years after he
left so maybe one day it did indeed on
the bonus show today a Playboy model is
facing jail for snapchatting a photo of
a naked 70 year old woman in a gym
locker room a man is suing his date for
texting during guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 we will find out whether pat has
ever filed a lawsuit against someone
he's been on a date with and I will also
talk to you about as news was breaking
yesterday about the James Comey memo
what was Fox News covering what was Fox
News covering all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership